[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing once again
the weasley family as well as the french
quarter villa
fleur de la cour bill weasley's bride
more specifically however we're going to
be discussing why
certain members of the weasley family
molly and ginny
disliked fleur sure she was dating and
later married bill weasley
and it's normal to be protective of your
family members but molly and ginny
certainly took it to the extreme before
we dive into it further
i want to mention that most of the
weasleys don't hate flor de la cour
the men of the family are actually
generally portrayed to have either a
neutral or positive perception of her
most likely due to her velar heritage
and striking good looks molly and ginny
on the other hand
weren't so easily impressed in fact
ginny went as far
as to refer to her as phlegm behind her
back
even calling her a cow on one occasion
here's the thing about fleur
she was very proud of her heritage and
this comes across in her demeanor
to a certain degree she was also very
outspoken
a good example of this was when she
visited hogwarts for the triwizard
tournament
during her visit she made a bit of a
habit of complaining about the school
constantly comparing it to her own
school bobatol
fleur showed similar behavior when
visiting the borough
comparing it to her own home this type
of behavior
tends to come across as snobbish and the
weasley women were certainly quick to
pick up on it
as for why molly and jenny disliked her
well there are a myriad of reasons
some fair and others extremely unfair
first
they judged her by her looks immediately
categorizing her
to fit the dumb blonde stereotype
secondly
fleur was a bit arrogant which robbed
both ginny and molly the wrong way
next there is of course the element of
motherly love
to molly only a perfect woman would be
worthy of her bill
and molly was still under the impression
that her relationship to bill
was largely superficial and physical
molly simply didn't believe that fleur
was good enough for bill
but that is primarily because she
overlooked all of fleur's positive
traits
on the slightly less grave side molly
was also irked by fleur's distaste
for her favorite singer celestina wobeck
ginny didn't like a few things about
fleur first
ginny felt that fleur talked down to her
but this
may very well have been justified given
how ginny treated her
next ginny was simply a bit threatened
by her ginny had a serious crush on
harry
for many years and to her fleur the
quarter wheeler that has all the men
drooling
was just another opponent here's the
thing though
flow was generally nice and if molly and
ginny weren't so quick to judge her
then they may have been able to see that
side of her rather than looking at
all of her negative traits under a
microscope
was fleur a bit arrogant yeah but were
molly and ginny a bit harsh
definitely fortunately molly and ginny
did eventually realize their mistake
of being too harsh on fleur this came
after fleur demonstrated her loyalty to
bill
following his debilitating injuries
inflicted at the hands of fenrir
greyback
when fleur stayed with bill after his
appearance changed as a result of his
injuries
it became clear that her relationship
with him wasn't just
superficial or physical they truly were
compatible
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please remember to
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
have a biscuit potter
you